[Music]
so this is - I'm back and this time I'm
gonna tell you a little bit of a secret
there's a rule in chess called the
square it's about I don't know what it's
about that's the point because I don't
know the rule of the square
somebody tried to teach it to me when I
was little
and I didn't really get it but I feel
like I've gotten away with it in most of
my games and I can sort of intuitively
feel what it's about and later you can
check it out on the Magnus trainer you
can learn about the square and you can
know what I never learned so what I will
instant show you is one of my
specialties it appears at least
something I've done twice it's turning
around a very bad Queen ending and
winning winning it with with with a pawn
that cannot be caught by the king
because apparently the king is not in
the square so what I did here is this
was an online game again stocks on the
grid shook from 2017 what I did is I I
think I've been worse for most of the
games as I usually am against Erick and
here I gave a check again I'm getting
mated with Queen d7 Queen f7 whatever
very soon if I don't give checks so I
have to give checks I think we were both
pretty short of time here again for
those who know Alexander group they know
that he's constantly short of time so it
wouldn't be wouldn't be a surprise and
here he made a fateful decision
he played twin to g3
and what happened is I I could see that
the checks were soon going to run out
forego Queen - II - he has Queen - s3
and yeah there there are no more checks
so at this point I thought I have to
take and then I think later so I took I
exchanged the Queen's and I cleared a
five and what is important now to know
is that the king is not in the square of
the pond if only I knew what that means
but in my experience it means that the
king cannot stop the pond but if you do
know the role of the square you don't
have to calculate it every single time
like I've been doing for 20 years it
should also be noted that in the case of
first of all there are many choices for
what's here you can go King h4 and I
have to keep continue checking and beg
for a perpetual which I probably will
will get King F for never a good idea to
place the king and the Queen on the same
diagonal loses the Queen h2 taking the
Queen on the next move and there was
also Queen King - f5 which is also not a
very good choice because of King sorry
the point of 706 Queen goes to f3 Queen
to f4 take it take it and I find and now
in now the king is in this square so we
can try to catch the pawn but it's not
going to be able to catch too
pawns that are running on the opposite
sides of the board simultaneously what I
can say though is that in this position
instead of going for instead of going
for King before trying to catch the pawn
he could go King to d6 instead I go a3
since King d8 trying to stop King coming
from to c7 doesn't work East 17 e8 King
e6 a 3d six and checkmate with d7 next
so I would have to go a 3 inside King c7
a to d6 a 1 Queen d7 King e7 d8 Queen
King tang-see 627 check king e5 once
again the diagonal king queen not a good
idea
quintics g7 jack taking the Queen next
and winning the game which goes to show
that even though the concept of the
square is an important one there are no
absolutes and thus in this case if I
would give a check on f3 King Queen goes
to f4 I would have to take upon d3 and
well gave another check and hope it will
be hope it will be enough
remember this was a internet blitz game
we are only a few seconds post though I
choose to believe that I would have been
fine but who knows anyway I was luckier
he went Queen g3 I took it
King takes g3 I went day five king is
not in time and it's neither in time to
Queen his dangerous passports nor is it
in this way
you can learn more about this on on
Magnus trainer and play - calm you can
also learn more about another nice
swindle I pulled off against Anand and a
blitz game where I also took advantage
of his King not being in the square in
lost queen endings so more good stuff
maybe I'm eventually gonna learn about
the square myself in that case I should
check it out
[Laughter]
[Music]